those nominated for Best Performance by
an actor this year are Marlon Brando for
The Last Tango in Paris Jack Lemmon for
save the tiger Jack Nicholson for the
last detail
Al Pacino for Serpico Robert Redford for
the sting the winner is Jack Lemmon
you were right well I tell you I I had a
speech prepared in 1959 I forgotten it
if I took the time to thank all of the
people very honestly that are
responsible for this award we'd be here
much too long but naturally Temari Ransa
hoffman filmways and paramount i am
deeply indebted for them letting Eva's
may even make the film because nobody
wanted to let us make it to Steve shaken
and John avildsen it would take much too
much and much too long and I'll have to
do it personally later and to a cast and
a crew of people I've never in my life
been connected with anything that meant
more to me and worked with so many
wonderful professional people that cared
and loved something so much and they
made it one of the great great moments
of my life the making of that film and
that's equal to this honor just the
privilege of working with them
truthfully and I thank them all and I
love them and respect them I just want
to say one more thing in recent years
especially there has been a great deal
of criticism about this award and
probably a great deal of that criticism
is very justified I would less like just
like to say that whether it's justified
or not I think it is one hell of an
honor and I am thrilled and I thank you
all